Speaker 1: continuing our sort of tour of
the news here.
It is now time for New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo to resign.
I that that is my view.
Joe Biden said the same yesterday and many
others as well.
He has been now accused and investigated for
sexually harassing multiple women.
We now have the results of an investigation.
CNBC summarizes it.
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo sexually harassed
multiple women who worked for the state and
elsewhere, according to a report by State
Attorney General Letitia James.
The investigation concluded Cuomo, quote,
violated federal and state law.
James said at a.
Press conference, Cuomo then retaliated against
the former employee who complained publicly
about his conduct, according to the report,
the probe into numerous women's allegations
of sexual harassment by Cuomo started in March
after the state's executive chamber granted
James's request to investigate further coverage
of this Albany D.A. criminally investigating.
Cuomo asks any victim of New York governor
sexual harassment to contact office.
The D.A. of Albany County said his office
is criminally investigating.
Cuomo D.A. David Sawers said his office would
welcome any victim to contact our office with
additional information about Cuomo.
Source said he plans to request investigative
materials from the state attorney general's
probe of the alleged harassment of 11 women.
So listen, for people who were saying, oh,
David, you partizan shill, and you'll bup,
bup, bup, bup.
No, hold on, guys.
We're going to have the same standard here
for left and right.
Earlier, there were allegations and an investigation
started.
And at that time I said, let's see what the
investigation finds.
We now have an investigation that appears
to have been done without obvious political
bias of some kind where the investigation's
results would not be trustworthy.
So although there have not been criminal charges
here, the investigation is credible.
And this, in my view now encumbers Andrew
Cuomo, his ability to just be the governor
to such a degree that I believe it is time
for him to resign.
I don't find myself even needing to say much
more about it.
It's just time for him to resign.
Now, interestingly, he put out an an 85, 85
page written response.
There's only 26 pages of text and a lot of
the pages are just pictures of Andrew Cuomo
and various types of embrace with different
figures, including Joe Biden, with his mom,
Matilda Cuomo with hurricane victims, Sandra
Patterson.
It's basically oh, I'm sorry.
This is an example of George W. Bush embracing
hurricane victims.
Sandra Patterson sort of saying, listen, this
type of hugging is not a big deal.
Lots of people do it.
Here's Barack Obama hugging Hillary Clinton.
It's really just not a big deal.
Also taking the approach in a video that he
put out of just saying, this is how I interact
with people.
I just hug people.
There's nothing inappropriate about it, which
is it's sort of like an affirmative defense.
He's not denying the contact with the women.
He's just saying this is no big deal.
Speaker 3: I do it with everyone bright black
and white, young and old, straight to an LGBTQ,
powerful people, friends, strangers, people
who I meet on the street.
Speaker 1: So I think it's an interesting
approach.
I don't think Andrew Cuomo survives this and
he should resign at this time.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I would love to hear
from you.